タンキンマンニャシ あなたはどのように思いますか？アーナンダよ
カンアッタワサンサンパッサマーナ
カンアッタワサンというのは
まあ何かこの目的というか
何かまあ 何のためというね
まあいわゆる目的のことですね
どのようにあのことを考えて利益を考えてサンパッサマーナ
まあそれ考えということですね
アラハティ・サーヴァコ・サッラーラン・アヌバンディトゥン
サッラーランっていうのはまあ師匠のことで
まあ先生のことで アヌバンディトゥンというのはまあ
まあ追っていくと いわゆるまあ
先生のまあ後ろから まあ一応歩くということで
アヌバンディトゥンって
従って行くっていうことですね
だからまあカンアッタワサンサンパッサマーナ
どんな 何のためにどんな目的を考えて
あの 師匠をサーヴァコ
弟子が あの 負うべきでしょうかと
ありますかね 三百六十五ページです
アーナンダよ このことをどう思いますか？つまり
弟子はたとえ拒絶されても
どのような道理を見て師に従うべきかということです
うんうん ということですね
まあ順番かなり変わりますから
アーナンダよ まあこの
何でしたっけ  このことをどう思いますか
そのことをどう思いますか
つまり弟子はたとえ拒絶されて
それはこのタンキンマンニャシという意味なんですね
で それからキンアッタワサンサンパッサマーナというの訳は
うーんと できないなぁ
どのような道理を見て師に従うべきかという
ということです  それで最後にアピパヌッジャマーナ
パーリ語で最後に入れてアピパヌッジャマーナ
追い出されてもというね
いや先生 それはあの 弟子はたとえ拒絶されてもというところに返るわけ
うん だから弟子を まあ師に追い出されて
まあ拒絶されて まあ追い出されても
やっぱりそれでもその師を追っかけて行った方がいい場合は
どの場合はそのことをやってもよろしいかと
まあまあ あんまり説明しない方がいいということですけど
まああの まあこの場合はこの師弟関係というものを説明しているんですね
まあまあ 経典の前のところは
まあ一応私にできる限りは説明しましたけど
まあいろいろ間違いあったかもしれませんし
それはまあ裏で批判すればよろしいし
前で質問 質問は出さないで
で  あいつは仏教わからない
間違ってるんだと まあ一応まあ知識的な勉強の場合は
何か気にかかったこと
引っかかったことっていうのはその場で聞くことですけどね
まあそれはそれで まあ次に
あの ですから 前のことを全然もう振り返してもそれほど何もしません
で 勝手にしてやってくださいっていうことで
あの次に あの 師弟関係って何なのかっていうところで
まあいろいろ師弟関係っていうのは
この世の中でありまして
インドの場合は まあ一応日本と違ってね
やっぱり師弟関係っていうのはちょっとあの
かなり厳密なもんなんですね
で 弟子についちゃって
一応勉強してみるし だからって他の先生のところに行くこともできるし
で だから ものすごく自由な世界でいる人々にとっては
こんな師弟関係っていうのは何なのかということはわからないかもしれませんしね
で こちらで言ってるのは
弟子をまあ一応先生が追い出すんですね
あんたはもう出て行けと
もうあんたはもう弟子として認めたくないと
それで認めたくないと追い出されても
追い出されても頑張って頑張って先生のところに行った方がいいというところなんですけど
だからといってそれで認めるわけにいきません
どんなような 何を認めて
そうやってこの先生にしがみつくんでしょうかというところで
このどんなような先生で
どんなような弟子であるべきかという
そこら辺は説明しようとしているんですね
そこでアナンダ尊者が bhagavaṃ
mūlakā no bhante dhamma bhagavā n
ettikā bhagavaṃ paṭisaraṇā sādhuvata bhante
bhagavantaṃ hi eva paṭibhātu hetaśśabhāti tassa attho bhagav
ato sutvā bhikkhu
dhāressantī’ti
で アナンダ尊者が別にそれわからないし
わからないだけではなくて
お釈迦様は最初に質問出したっていうことは
そこら辺をお釈迦様は説明したがっているんですよ
ですから 昔の弟子たちはそれをすごい理解してて
すぐ質問するんですね
そこら辺 説明 説明しようとしてるんだと
先生は だったら先生が説明しやすくするために質問しようではないかという悪い性格があったんですね
今と違って それでアナンダ尊者が
まあ法っていうのはbhagavaṃ mūlakā
お釈迦様はまあ根源であると bhagavā
nettikā まあ法っていうのは
まあお釈迦様が導いてリーダーになって
リーダーはお釈迦様でbhagavaです bhagavaṃ
paṭisaraṇā
この真理はまあお釈迦様に頼っているんだと
拠り所にしてるんだと
[外国語]ですから サーデュワタバンティバガヴァンタンイワパティバート
ですから その答えはお釈迦様に思い出すように
お釈迦様はどのようにこの質問にお考えになっているんでしょうかと
その方が説明した方がよろしいんではないかと
だから私の意見 あの人の意見とかね
師弟関係についてね いろいろ意見言うよりは
法はお釈迦様が根源であってお釈迦様に頼っていて
お釈迦様はリーダーであって
ですからお釈迦様が教えた方がよろしいんじゃないかなという風に
パティバートエータッサバーティタスバーシタッサアット
今おっしゃった言葉の意味は
お釈迦様の理解の通りによろしいと
バガートスッタは釈迦様から聞いて
ビクダーレサンティティ比丘たちは理解するだろうと
ネクーアーナンダラハティサーワコサッチャーランアヌバンディトゥンヤディダンスッタンゲイヤンゲイヤーカラナッサヘトゥ
タンキッサヘトゥディーガラッタッサヒウォアーナンダダッマ
スッタダタワジャッサパリチッタマナッサーヌペッキッタディッティヤスッパティヴィッダ
ヤーチャコヤンアーナンダカタアビサンレキッタチェトーヴィヴァラナサッバーヤ
エーカンタニムビッダーヤヴィラーガーヤニローダーヤウパサマーヤアヴィンヤーヤサンボーダーヤニッバーナーヤサンワッタビセイヤテーダン
アッピッチキャカタサントゥッティカタパヴィヴェーカカタアサンサッガカタ
ヴィリーヤラムキャカタシーラカタサマーディカタパンニャーカタヴィムッティカタヴィムッティニャナダッサンナカタ
エーバルーピヤーコアーナンダカタヤヘトゥアラハティサーワコサッチャーランアヌバンディトゥンアピパユッジャマーノー
そこでこの まあなんで先生のところに行くかというと
それ先生からいろいろ勉強してもらうためなんですね
そこでお釈迦様の場合は
お釈迦様を先生にしてお釈迦様のところに弟子入り弟子入りする場合も
お釈迦様の話を聞きたいという気持ちはあるんですね
そこで他のところでも
お釈迦様が説法するときは
お釈迦様はこの九つの方法で説法しているんだから
説法する方法が経典 今経典にもなっています
九つあるんだと それはスッタンゲイヤンゲイヤーカラナ
ジャータカどこでしたっけ？スッタンゲイヤンゲイヤーカラナ
それしか書いてないな
とにかくこの同じ経典どこかで出てくるはずなんです
全部リスト スッタンゲイヤンゲイヤーカラナン
ジャータカアブダダンマン
デダッランなんとかなんとか
九つの法があるんだと
それで注釈書では それはこのお釈迦様がおっしゃった教えは全部その九つに分け分けられ分けられると
では思っているし 大乗経典になってくると時代になってくると九つは十二になっていくんですね
で この十二のカテゴリーの法があるんだと
教えがあるんだというね
で どちらにしたっても
その九つって何なのかっていうのは
北伝も南伝もあまりわかっていなかったみたいんですね
ですから まあとにかく
スッタっていうのはスートランタという経典みたいなことで
この前説明しましたから
それを思い出してみてください
九つの一つ一つ説明しました
ゲイヤっていうのはこのゲイとサンと両方混ぜてあるもので
日本語で何と言いますかね
それは 三分と何とか分なんですね
韻文と散文両方あって
喋る場合はゲイヤというし
ヴァイヤーカラーナっていうのは
この質問形式で あの これは何なのか
その場合はこれこれやと
こういう場合は何なのかと
これはこういうことだという風に
このダイアログ質問形式で喋ることがヴァイヤーカラーナ
それでガータンというのは
まあただ歌で散文だけでまあ喋るというね
まあ全部一つ歌を作った
まあ詩を作って まあ詩でずっと説法するというのがガータン
ウダーナっていうのは何かに感動して
何かね まあその感動の表現ですね
まあイティヴッタカンというもう言い方がありまして
イティヴッタカンっていうのはもう
何かに引用して で この間
まあなんとかなんとか言ったら
こういうことを言ったんではないかと
それはどういう意味でしょうかとかね
そういう風に何かに引用してすること
話すことなんですね ですから
お釈迦さんもいろんなことに引用して喋った可能性はあるし
で 昔の人々はこんなこと言ったんではないかとかね
それから自分自身でもおっしゃったことに
また二番目に私はなんとかなんとか
場所でこういうふうなことを言いましたよと
ということ 自分のことに引用して
それはどういう意味でしょうかっていう風に
まあこうやって そういう形式で喋るんですね
うん それからアブダダンマンという
あの 話し方がありまして
普通の人々はびっくりする
なんか理解できない なるほど不思議だなという
そういうふうな この感覚を
これは不思議と そういうふうな感覚を
気持ちをね 引き起こしながら喋る方法っていうのはアブダダンマンということで
で それからウェーダンランということがありまして
ウェーダンランって何なのか誰もわかってないみたいんですけど
あの それはまあ アビダンマ大になってくるとワイプッリラになってきて
それはおそらくまあ大乗では中論やら句論も喋ることやと言ってますけどね
まあそれはまあいい加減なことなんですけど
ワイプッリラっていうのは
おそらくこの すごいこのソクラテスの話みたいな感じで
あの ものすごいこの淡々と
この厳密に この論理的な哲学的なことを喋ると
で その場合は聞く相手はね
どんな人でもいいわけじゃなくてね
ちゃんと相手もすごく喜んで
ものすごいこの知識の言葉
淡々と喋る いわゆる哲学
ソクラテスの話聞いたとかね
で という風な驚きますね
話を聞いて すごい頭ではなんかすごいいいことを教えてくれたとかね
で そういう風なこの知識的な話がウェーダンランということになって
それで全部九つなんですよ
で そういう教え方があるんです
説法の仕方があるんです
ここでお釈迦様が言うのは
このスッタゲイアヴァイヤーカラーナウンオンを
のために弟子入りしてはいけませんと
いわゆるお釈迦様の話を喜ぶために
ただ あの あいつの話もな
聞いていられますよ まあ聞いてると楽しいですよとかね
そういう まあ歌あるいはディッサ
労働あるわ 血あるわ もうすごい感動的な話もあるとかね
だからもう行って色々側にいて
ずっと話もそっちを聞いてみましょうという
そこはもうもうそうやんなく
そんな感じで弟子入りするなよという
まあまあ一応まあまあ
こちらのポイントは全く質問しなくて
ポイントはこのこういうポイントなんですね
だからお釈迦様は一応ものすごいこの話術を持っていて
人間っていうのはもうどんな風に喋れば喋れば理解するか
集中して話を聞いてくれるかっていうところは知っていたみたいし
で そこら辺で まあ詩で言う場合
言うべき時は詩で言うし
ものすごい感動的な言葉で言う時は
言うべき時はそういう風に喋るし
すごい厳密に何かもう授業みたいで
もう論理的に分析して喋る喋るべき時はそういう風に喋るという風に
まああらゆる方法を喋っているんですね
それでこの話術に話術に惹かれて
で たくさん弟子を入れてくれるっていうのは
まあ世の中は大体話術だけで十分ですよ
まあ大体どんな人でもものすごく上手に言葉を使うんだったら
まあそれで人間としては十分ですよ
で 喋る内容はどうでもいいんです
ですから 世の中大体要求しているのは上手に喋る
喋っているかないかということなんですね
ですから この 内容では決してありません
だからもうこの世の中でうまく人気者で
ものすごく収入もあって
どんな仕事でも金儲かるためにはるものだから
ものすごく収入を得て生活したければ
やっぱりまあ言葉を上手に喋る
上手に書く 内容はまるっきり関係ない
内容なんか入っちゃうともう困るんですよ
結局は ですから このすごいもう世界的なもうそういう優秀なね
書き屋さんとかね 喋る人やと言っちゃうと
まるっきり何も内容喋れませんね
内容ないんですよ 内容ないんだけど
1時間でも2時間でも3時間を喋る能力というのは大したもんですよ
だからいろんなところでは引用しますよ
引用しただけでびっくりして
いきなり数字を出しちゃって
で まあそこでものすごいびっくりして
まただから何ということじゃなくて
そうやってこの まあ大体テレビのアナウンサーやらね
もう喋ることを見ると
もうすごく そういう風にこの何とかのあの番組で何か手紙はあの
たくさん来てましたと
1万ちょっと枚数なんですけど
それぐらいの手紙来ていたんです
だからかなりみんな見ているんだよというふうに
ある男が言うと 女の人はということは一応なんとか何とかで全然見ていないということですねとかね
だから手紙出したのは 1万人ぐらいだから
まあ日本人口からね それを引いて
それでみんなまあすごく楽しくて拍手するんで
その言葉に それが話術ということなんですね
だからあの女に まあそこら辺にいて
誰かがディレクターが
まあその じゃあお前はこういう風に喋りなさいと
お前はこういう風にこの番組を引き立てなさいと
2万人の返事がありました
なんとこんなにあると思わなかったんですよと
そしたら あの女がすごい四角い顔で
ということは 一応なんとか見てないということですねとかね
で まあまあ そういう風に
それでみんなもうすごい抜群な番組だと
で 結局何言ってるんで
それでということはね
だからかなり話術でないと
そういう風に話すっていうことはできないんですね
だからそれだけで十分なんですよ
人間にとっては だから決してこの意味を通じるということは
もう世の中では存在しないんですね
ですから 意味を書いても読まないんですよ
だからただ言葉で何か間違いでもありますかとか
それだけ調べているだけでね
まあだからそれはもう残念なことに
遠い昔のお釈迦様は知っていたんですね
話術というものは世の中でちゃんとあることで
で まあ悪いことに お釈迦様にもすごい言葉で上手でしたし
だからもうものすごいもう大量に人が集まるっていうことも避けられないんですね
話を聞くために 面白いということで
で そういうで お釈迦様はそれをもう嫌で嫌で追い出したいんですね
だから私の弟子入り人入り人いる人々が決してこのこの話術を目指してきてはいけませんと
だからスッタゲッジャガイヤカラーナというのは話術っていうわけじゃなくて
お釈迦様の説法そのものなんですよ
説法を目指して来るなよっていうことなんです
で 本当の意味は説法ということですね
師は説法してるんではないかと
じゃあ説法を聞きましょうという意味で弟子入りしてはいけませんと
なんででしょうかね そういう話を聞く目的で来るなと言ってるのは
で この法というのは 説法っていうのはどうしても知識的な勉強なんですね
話術だけではないんです
ディーガラッタッスヒョアナンタダンマツカ
この法というものはディーガラッタ
もう長い間みんなもうよく聞いて勉強しているんですよ
ダタ それから覚えてるんですね
それからワジャサパリジタ
ワジャサっていうのは発音して発音してお釈迦様の教えをね
唱えて唱えて ものすごく自分でそれをパリジタ訓練してるんですね
だからお釈迦様の教えをもう長い間ものすごく聞いて
聞いて それから理解も覚えておく
暗記もして 暗記しただけではなくて
訓練もするんですね 発音して
発音して 発音して訓練もしています
マナサーヌペッキタ それだけじゃなくて
頭の中で考えることもしているんですね
どんな意味かと それからディッティアスッパティッダ
ディッティアっていうのは
この このお釈迦様のヴィッシャンをよく理解する
自分でも同じヴィッシャンを得るということなんですね
これは現代人がやらないことで
で 人の話をね 聞いて勉強すると
ただ聞いてテープラコーダーに入れておいて
どこかに捨てるということで
全てわかったことにはなりませんし
あるいはただ何回何回も回して
まあこの人の声を聞くとよく眠れますよという
この睡眠薬代わりに使うとかね
で それも勉強ということにはならないし
で まあわちらの話はどうせ意味がないんだからそれでいいんですけど
やっぱりどこかにね 学校やらどこかに人の話なんか聞く場合はね
で まあその人々はちゃんと大事な話をしていますね
ですから 人の話を聞いて
ただもうなんとか聞いて聞いてわかっただけでは足らないんですよ
だからマナサワ マナサワヌペッキタっていうのは
自分の頭でもなるほどなるほど
そういうことか とかそういうことかというふうに頭でいろんな思索していることなんですね
ですから 耳で聞く それから頭で覚えておく
それから自分で口でもその言葉を唱えて
まあもう習ってみる 訓練してみる
それで頭でもなんとか理解しようとすることはマナサーナ・ペッキタ
ディッティヤ・スッパティヴィッダということは大体はやりません
ディッティヤっていうのは見だと書いていると思いますけど
日本訳は あの その人のビジョンなんですね
この人はどんな哲学 どんなビジョンを持ってるかという
その思想体系に自分がぎっしりと入り込んで
それをそのまま あ こういうことを教えてるんだというふうに理解することなんですね
そうすると 初めてその人の教えを勉強したことになります
だから 鵜呑みにする意味ってはないんです
だから 一般的に私の感想では
なんかみんなそこはもう西洋思想でない限りは
このこの論理を理解することをすごく嫌がるんですね
なんでそんな汚いことを理解してしなくちゃあかんかとかね
まあ西洋思想だったら
もうわが師匠のように
なんかすごい思い上がってやってるでしょうね
だからそれでもわかってないということを私は思いますけどね
ただ猿真似だけではないかと
だから人の話を理解するってことはもうちょっと違うんですよ
で まあキリスト教の教えを勉強したいと思うならば
やっぱりその思想がどのように考えて
どんな哲学で どんな論理で
どういう風になっているかということじゃ身についてないと勉強したことにならないんですね
そういうふうに勉強すれば
自分がキリスト教でなくても
まあこういう質問が出て
キリスト教だったらこういう答え出しますよと
ちゃんとこの思索思想パターンというのが身につくんですね
だから人々はもう何か経験があって喋ってますからね
その中に入って理解しないと意味がないんです
ただ その人はこういう言葉言いました
こういう言葉言いましたとかね
ですから この我々インド系の人々は
あなたはこういう言葉を言ったんではないかとかかってくると
その瞬間でもうもうゴミにしているんです
相手を で 一応答えるんだけど
もうただのもう生ゴミ
知識がないんだと だから大事なことはもう何か言葉はこういうこと言った
それじゃないんですよ
法律じゃないんだから
この思索というか この中身の哲学なんですね
だから中身のあなたこういうこと言うんだけど
こういう風に見ると なんかちょっと納得いかないよと言っちゃうと
あ この人は中身ぶつかってるんだと
そこですごく面白くなってくるんですね
だから昨日勉強に来たあの男性の質問はね
やっぱりそう言って 本当に中身の中身の中身のもうすごい難しいんですよ
そこはもう誰も聞 interest かないところで
でももう淡々と質問する
でもそれはきちんと中身を聞くんですね
で そうすると すぐ淡々とこちらでも答えるしか方法ないんですね
あれやこれやとかね もう言う必要なくなっちゃうし
実はそうなってるのはこういうわけですよと
こうなってるのはこういうわけですよと
だから表面的に見ると
なんかブッダの教えに真っ向から逆らって質問するような聞こえます
でもそうじゃないんです
その人を別に真っ向から逆らおうとかどういうことではなくて
まあただお釈迦様の思想体系
お釈迦様自身の哲学に対して
自分が見出したちょっとした矛盾というか
なんとかというそこら辺なんですね
だから言葉に引っかかってきたわけじゃないんです
そういうことで このお釈迦様の教えっていうのは
そういう順番でみんなやってるんだと
暗記するは覚えていくは
弟子たちと一緒に唱えているわ
それから理解しようともするわ
それからその思想体系の中に入り込んで
まあブッダの世界はこういう世界だと
ブッダに見られた世界はこういう世界
ブッダに見られた人生観はそういう人生観だという風に
その中にまで入って 哲学まで勉強しているんだと
みんな長い間 ということで
何です 何をおっしゃりたいんですかね
この場合はサカさまは
だからお釈迦様の教えを勉強したければ
私のところに弟子入りしなくたっての
そこら辺の教会に行って神父さんに会ったって
仏教ぐらいは勉強できますよ
だってその人の本なんか持ってますからね
仏教のテキストやら何か勉強したければ
もうどこら辺もカトリック教会に行ったって
おそらくパリのパリであろうか
日本校の仏典やらもうあると思いますよ
金持ちのところだから
バチカンに行ったっても
もうかなり仏典いろいろあると思いますよ
あるものはそれぞれの専門家にさせてたって
みんなそれなりに勉強したりはしています
だから 朝とブッダに弟子いるとかね
誰かお坊さんに話を聞く必要全くない
そこら辺に行けばいいんです
もっとすごい贅沢に格好よく勉強することもできると思いますね
だから 勉強ぐらいだったらどこででもできるんだよということなんです
そこで厳密に あの 何て言いますか
理屈 論理をもう理解したいという
まあ西洋思想と比較しながら
なんとか何とか思想と比較しながら
もう勝手にいくらでもどこでもできるんですよ
そんな だから そのためにはブッダのところに来るなよと
どこら辺のもうもう大学もいっぱいあるし
全く仏教を信仰してないんですよ
もう大学の教授だって
でも ものすごい世界的な仏教の教授なんですよ
私が知ってるのはみんなもう絶対輪廻なんかは信じません
なぜ？何でですか？アメリカではそんな話はないんだと
でもギリギリとブッダを言うんです
漢文で読むわ サンスクリット語で読んでるわとかね
そこでも訂正までこのサンスクリット文書はそうじゃなくてこうなるべきですよとかね
すごい専門家なんですよ
まあアビダンマにしたってもね
ものすごい専門的な知識がありますよ
ですからまあこういうブッダのところには来るなよと
もうそんなにもうめんどくさいしね
そんなにもう学問的なもうやりたければ
もうそういう学者のところに行った方がいいというところなんですね
こちらで昔から言ってるのは
で それであの心配はないんだと
だってちゃんと教えてるテキストできてるんだから
それは何人語それテキストを読んでみたっても変化できませんだから
そういう心配はないんですよ
だから英語でもフランス語でもパーリ経典でもいろいろ訳があります
英語だったら全部訳あるし
まあドイツ語か何語か今またいくつか訳しているし
昔はもうソ連のロシア語でもいろいろありましたからね
それで昔はいたんですよ
仏教学者が すごい立派な本をものすごいもう驚くほど立派な本とか書かれてありましたで
一応日本英訳もあるしね
ドイツロジックというテキストはもうソ連人の学者が書いたもんで
あれはインドのサンスクリット語にあったロジックの本をね
翻訳したのってなかなか難しいんですよ
ちゃんとロシア語にありましたしね
ですから そういう人々に行って勉強してもらえば
まあ立派に学問的に教えてくれるんですね
だから心配はないと とそこら辺に長い間それはもう確定して
対策する方法までもう確定しているんだからね
教えはね お釈迦様にとってはすごい何かもう子供たちが勉強に学校に来たような感じでお釈迦様のところに来ると
これやりきれないんですよ
来るなよと 学校っていくらでもあるんだからね
そちらに行って勉強しなさいということで
やーちゃこーあやんあなんだけかあびさっれーきかーちぇーとーぎわらなさったやえかんたにんびだーや
びらーがーや にろーだーや
うぱさまーや あびんにゃーや
さんぼーだーや にっばーなーや
さんわったて そこで またお釈迦様のところに弟子入りすれば
またお釈迦様がいろんなことを話はしますよ
お釈迦様はスッタで言ういやがるのではなくて
話術でいろいろ喋るんではなくて
学者で教授でいろんなことを喋るんじゃなくて
ごく一般的なイランのことを喋るんだと
それはどういう話かというと
アビ・サッレーキタ アビ・サッレーキタっていうのはね
削って減らしたものに削り取って減らしていく
削減の  削減の意味だけ
削減の話って何ですかね
余分なものを削り取る
と解釈したらダメですか
だからこれ日本語訳しているんだから
日本語で何か意味が通るでしょうね
おそらく  通るような 通らないような
私はずっと自分の訳すてきたんだけど
誰も相手にしなかったしね
これいいと思っていたし
これで決めたんです 私は教える方法を日本語訳を中心にするんだと
手本にしてやっちゃおうと思って
よく私はわからないんだから
削減の話って何でしょうかと
まあまあパーリ語でわかってますけどね
まあでも 一応パーリ語でこのアビ・サッレーキタという言葉は日本語で削減という風になってます
で だからといってパハ―の減るとかね
その時の削減という言葉使いますけど
あのそれと同じじゃないと思いますけどね
で この辞書を引いてみたっても
必ず同じ言葉が出てくると思います
削減のとか もう一つ 三減のと三減のっていうこともありますけどね
もう 何かね いい言葉がないかな
ないと思いますけどね
削減の話って言えばどういう話でしょうかね
減らすじゃいけないんです
減らすじゃいけない  だから減らす話ってどういう話ですかね
リストラ  え？ リストラ
話の太さを真髄に向かって無駄なものを一つずつ減らしていく
だったら結局喋らない方がいいでしょうに
喋らなきゃ困るんです
肝心なところは  喋る場合は
肝心なところだけ喋って黙っているのは失礼でしょうしね
明確に説明して喋るのは正しい
相手がわからなかったり
そのことを喋っても相手がわからなかったりする
余分なことも喋らないと理解できない人もいるかもしれないし
だから減らすことについて話す
減らすことについて この言語を分解したらいかんでございますか？ だから学者の学者様方はアビ・サッレーキタっていうことは
そうやって削減というふうに翻訳しているんだから
まあそれはそれは私が何回言ったっても認められませんでしょうね
それはそれなりってことなんで
私は何言ったってもそれもう意味がないんです
まあとにかく学者に言えるものは学者にいるところで
で まあ注釈書を見ても意味がないんでしょうし
まあだから注釈書を見ても出てこないと思います
だから学者はいくら翻訳したって今翻訳できないんです
注釈書で出てこないのはそれなりの訳があるんです
そういうものは他のところで別な場所でちゃんと翻訳注釈しているんです
ですから 仏教の人々は知ってるんです
意味は そこで出るたびにそちらの翻訳はしません
基本用語だから でも学者の場合はその場所で翻訳していないとわからない
じゃあその場所場所によって訳し方が違うということですか
その状況の  そういう話じゃないんですけど
アビサルレギタということ言葉の意味は
言葉の意味は出てこないんですよ
だから注釈書にはそこないんだから
でも他のところではあると思います
どうしようかな 何番でした？これは
何番？この経典は  経典は百二
百二条  このコンテキストから見れば
後ろの方のため これはもうコンテキストから見なくちゃわかんないですよ
そこだけ言ったって  だから私には日本語の言葉を思い出せないんですよ
別にパーリ語から見れば全然何の問題もない言葉ですよ
日本語訳ではそうなってますけど
パーリ語的には何のこともない
この前も何回も出ましたし
この勉強会でも私はアビサルレギタということを説明したんですよ
聞き覚えがありますけど
なんかかっこいい言葉がないですからね
アビサルレギタっていうのは
このヒラサという意味ではありません
で これは道徳的な人の生き方について喋る時の使う言葉であって
まあしつけというか もうもうまあ
そういう日本語の場合も言葉がないんですね
説法はあるんだけど もうお話っていう言葉があるんだけど
話もいろいろあるんですよ
人間が何をするべきか
何をしてはいけないかということは淡々と喋る
アドバイスの話がありますよ
で アドバイスと言っちゃうと
また日本語でまた変な意味でしょうに
ですから もうまあ 本当の英語の意味ではもうアドバイスですよ
レプリマンドという言葉もあります
アドバイスという言葉もあります
うん だから法の場合はドクトリンとかね
もうといういろいろもあります
それは一つ一つ書く言葉の目安が違うんですね
で レプリマンドという言葉なんですよ
諭すっていうのは違いますか
ん？ 諭すっていう  うーん
レプリマンドは諭すじゃないんですよ
わきまえ  ん？ わきまえ
うん ねぇ まぁ辞書でもあればね
調べますけどね おそらくレプリマンドだと思いますね
英語の言葉は  持っておきます
で 一応アドバイスすることで
この人間はいろんなことをやって生活してるんですよ
そこはもうあまりにも良くなくて
あまりにも良くなくて
もう堕落するんですね
そこでどういう風に生きていればいいかとかわからないんですね
そこで喋ってあげるんですよ
こういうこういうものは削減しなさいと
この子の行動をやめなさいと
喋る場合は喋ってもいいんだけど
こういう話し方は削減しなさいと
食べてもいいんだけど
こういう食べ方は削減しなさいと
歩いてもいいんだけど
こういう歩き方はやめなさいという風に
とことんもう生き方 喋る
だから削減という言葉になってるんですけど
削減という意味ではないんですね
結局は 一応話の中でこういうこういうことは戒めなさい
自習しなさいと  この前の前に削減って日本語で出てきた時に
確かそのように先生からお聞きしたっていうのを今なんとなく思い出して
で 私はその時 物事をわきまえるってことかなって心の中でちょっと思ったんです
まあ日本語ではないでしょうね
叱るというぐらいしかないんですけど
日本語だったら  叱るっていうので近寄るとしつけるとか
しつけ叱る うん  そういった感じの方向に行きます
うん やっぱりレプリマンドはこちらもね
なんとか何か戒と書いてますけど
読めない 戒戒わからない
叱るとなんとかですね
かなり時間かかります
思い出しました 確か先生がそういう風にご説明いただいたと思いました
レプリマンドって場所を探すの時間がかかるんです
すいません  頑張って  懲戒
懲戒 うん  懲戒する  戒めるというような意味ですね
しつける 日本人の間ではやっぱりわきまえがないから
こういうことをしつけるとか
そういう意味じゃないかと思います
だからちゃんとわきまえあって
それはすごい なんとなくかっこいい言葉で
もうそれじゃないんですね
しつけることを懲戒ですよ
まあ懲戒と言っていいと思いますね
あまりかっこいい言葉ではないんです
聞きなれない 懲戒 懲戒という言葉は生活の中で出てこない
しつけるっていうのは
よく子供をしつけるとか
そういう意味では使いますけど
でも懲戒というのは意味が強いですよ
そうそう 懲戒免職とか
だからわけじゃない 申し渡して諭すとか
そういう意味でしょ いやもうちょっと意味がね
悪い方に そういう風に解釈すればね
懲戒免職とか 後から免職って言葉がつくと
懲戒免職って続けて解釈すればいい言葉ではない
懲戒っていうのはあまり強いでしょ
うんアドバイスでいいんじゃないですか
アドバイスでいいんですけど
アドバイスは日本語じゃないんですけど
みんな知ってるから でも先生のおっしゃりたい奥のあれはやっぱり私たちで受け取りにくい部分があるんだ
先生の中ではもうお分かりになってて
日本語のアドバイスはまあなんとなくすごいこの
あまりにも軽すぎ まあ懲戒なんですけど
まあ懲戒といったっても漢字
漢字としてはね また意味がガタガタで完璧じゃないし
まあ懲戒ほどのものでもないんですけど
アドバイスと懲戒の中間ぐらいなもんなんです
忠告するとか  忠告  戒めるっていうような感じ
まあ戒めの話ですよ まあ一般的に言えばね
戒めですよ 説法はするんだけど
完全に戒め中心にやるというね
これからどうするべきかというふうな話なんですね
次の言葉はチェトー・ヴィヴァラナ・サッバーヤ
チェトー 心 ヴィヴァラナっていうのはこのガードすることですね
えーと 削減 心の障害を離れるためにふさわしい
チェトー・ヴィヴァラナ・サッバーヤはふさわしい
まあこの場合も伝統的にこの日本訳もなんぼやってますけど
やっぱり言語 言葉から見れば
これは心をガードするという意味でいいと思います
で ヴィヴァーレティっていうのはプロテクションというね
まあ言われれば 何々か危険から守るということで入らないようにする
だから心を一応警備しておくんですね
心を警備する場合は 敵が外から来るんですね
だから障害というのは
心の中にも障害ある場合あるんですね
うん ですから チェトー・ヴィヴァラナっていうのは
チェトーは心です 心に警備をつける
敵が入らないようにという
いわゆる まあここは簡単には心の障害なんですけど
心の障害を取り除くためにサッバーヤ
サポートになるもの ですから
まあ現代日本語訳すれば
心を警備に当たる話 心をどのように警備すれば
護せれば 守ればよろしいかという
その話を聞いたら すぐ心を守ることができるようになるんですね
それからエーカント・ニッビダーヤ
お釈迦様の話場合は この話はエーカント
極端に 一方的に ニッビダーヤ
解脱にいくんですね いわゆるこのあれこれと人の話にはめげない
全然もうそう言われたっても仕事しなくちゃあかんだと
そういう生ぬるい話は聞かない
だったら仕事辞めなさいと
お釈迦様はこうやって解脱しなさいと言ったっても
うちの奥さんは結婚してて
だ 捨てなさいと それ言い訳は何一つも聞かない
エーカンタっていうのは absolute ということで
もう一方通行 徹底的に涅槃を目指している
解脱を目指している話なんですね
だからエーカンタ・ニッビダーヤ
ヴィラーガヤという言葉にもエーカンタ入るんで
エーカンタ全部に入ります
ヴィラーガヤ 厭離 欲から離れる
徹底的に徹底して欲から離れる話をする
次にニローダーヤ 滅ですね
煩悩をなくすこと だから徹底的に煩悩をなくす方向へしゃべる
ウパサマーヤ 徹底的に平安の安らぎのためにしゃべる
アヴィンニャーヤ 徹底したこの超越した智慧
俗世間の智慧じゃなくて
この超越した智慧を目指して話をしていますね
サンボーダーヤ 悟りのためにしゃべる
ニッバーナへ 涅槃のためにしゃべると
サンガたり そういうものに導く
だからお釈迦様の話は
徹底的に一方通行的に何に導くかというと
ニッビダーヤ ニッビダーヤっていうのはこの
面白くなくなるんですよ
ニッビダっていうのは面白くないって意味なんです
まあ嫌だと思うこと いわゆる世の中
俗世間で溺れて もう遊んでいる生活についてはものすごくもう嫌悪感じる
嫌悪感 なんて気持ち悪くて嫌なものだという
心はもう俗世間からきちっと逆に返ってもらうんですね
だからニッビダっていうのは
このものすごくもう大便食べさせるようなぐらいの感情なんですよ
まあありがたいとお醤油ぐらい入れちゃえば食べられますよとか
そんな話じゃないんですよ
すごい嫌なんですね それを強引に食べさせると
もうもう食べられ 殺すかもしれませんと
殺されるかもしれないが
食べると食べるかもしれませんだけど
嫌々やってますよ だからニッビダっていうのはそれぐらいの感情なんです
俗世間についてはものすごい嫌悪感を感じて
ものすごいなんかもうもう品位がなくて嫌という風に
だからお釈迦さんの話はやっぱり一応そういう風な方向へ導いてあって
それからエーカンタ・ニッビダ・ヴィラーガヤ
欲がなく 厭離のことで
ネーサンはニローダーヤ
煩悩はなくなる ウパサマーヤ
心は平安になる アヴィンニャーヤ
超越した出世間な智慧
出世間的な智慧が生まれる
サンボーダーヤ 悟りが生まれる
ニッバーナへ 涅槃に至るという話するんですね
だからお釈迦様のところに弟子入りすれば
この厳密に仏教学問は聞いてくれませんね
教えてくれません 四聖諦はありきやとかね
それもう苦聖は 苦 正体は何ぞやとかね
それはこれこういうものでありとかね
そこで諸苦とは何ぞやとかね
そんなのはもうないんです
どこら辺に誰で そこら辺に行って誰かから勉強してこいと
そんなものは だからこの仏教は学問としての話を理解するためには来るなよと
そんなものは長い間 お釈迦様は説いて定めて
もうこれがテキストだというふうにしているんですよ
俺も若い時も全部仏教はこれぐらいやと
全部もうさっさっさっと投げて
テキストは テキストはないんだけど
一応あの誰の中でも 仏教
仏説はこれですということは
認めてまとめてもう整えてあったんです
だからそれはもう誰からでも聞いたらわかりますよと
みんなもう勉強家たちだからね
仏教を理解したければ
別にお釈迦様のところに行く
そこら辺のヒンドゥー教の
もうどこかのジャイナ教の誰かのところに行ったっても
すぐわかってるんですよ
もうサマナはこういうことおっしゃってますよと
勉強ぐらいは だからそんなのを勉強するために私のところに来るんじゃないと
私のところに来るんだったら
すっごいすっごい力強く
ものすごい攻撃的で ものすごいもう爆弾的に
お釈迦様は個人的には喋ってるんですよ
だからアビサリーキタという言葉っていうのは
みんな聞いて嫌だって逃げるぐらいのきつい話なんです
[背景音楽]時々お釈迦様の話をあまりにきつすぎて
アビサルレキタアヤンサノゴトお釈迦様の悪口まで言うんですよ
お釈迦様やりすぎやと
そこまで言う必要はないんだと
で だからアビサルレキタという言葉はパーリ語の語にしたっても
あんまりあの愛情のある言葉じゃない
あまり気に入られる言葉じゃないんですよ
これは懲戒 懲戒なんですよ
懲戒というのは日本語でもすごくなんかもう嫌な言葉でしょうに
だから懲戒を重んじる話なんですよ
だから恐ろしい 怖い ビシビシよ
甘いとか なんとか優しいとか
ひとかけらもない 宗教だからもうちょっと優しく
もうちょっと手柔らかにとかね
もうちょっと信者さんのことは礼をしてとかね
神社の宮司さんみたいにね
仏教では絶対そんなことないんです
ブッダのところでは 穏やかな言葉とかね
全然一つもない だから人はけなしませんよ
人はけなしません なんてますか
侮辱はしません それ勘違いして欲しくない
人を侮辱しないというのは
これは常識ですけどね
だからすごく なんていうんですか
温厚ななんとか なんとかとかね
円満なとか すごく心に優しい
一つもないんですけど
だからこのそこら辺は誤解してほしくない
厳しいんですよ 厳しいと言ったって
お前この野郎死んでしまえとかね
そういう品のない話じゃないんです
だから そういう個人のね
態度を傷つけて 個人の人格を壊しちゃったりしてね
そういうこのヤクザみたいなね
そういう話はしませんと
これはものすごい知識的な智慧の話なんですけど
甘い話にはなりませんね
やめることとかやめなさいと
やめたくないんだったら出て行きなさいと
あんた成長したければ
こういうこういう決まりはやりなさいと
ちょっとと言ったって
私の腰が痛い じゃあただ帰れと
じゃあもう出て行け 出て行けと
今とはものすごく違うんですよ
だから 例えば若いお坊さんたちが遠くから来て
まあ来たばっかりだからちょっと声が高かったんです
ちょっとまあ なんとか
なんとかされたんですよ
自分の仲間の間で お釈迦様からもちょっと声がでかい
ほんのちょっとでかかっただけ
ほんのちょっとお釈迦様いるところに声が届いた
ただそれだけなんですよ
その会場っていうのはすごい大きいところでしたから
あのお釈迦様いた部屋は
まあそれも結構大きい部屋でした
今もありますけどね で
そちらにあっちこっちで森の細道の坊さんの声が聞こえたんですよ
いきなり誰ですか？の声出したの？って
それはあの遠くで 遠くからもう何ヶ月もかけて若いお坊さんたちがグループが来ているんだと
ああ 追い出しなさい 私のところにいるべきではありませんと
サマナゴータマのバグアというお寺の場合ね
お釈迦様のところではいるいてはいけませんと
追い出しますと もう顔も合わせてないんですね
しょうがないんですよ
それでもアナンガ尊者にそう言われたら
アナンガ尊者がサーリプッタ尊者に
もうそういうことにお釈迦様はこういうことを
あ そうですかと じゃあ帰りますと
何のことなく追い出されたらもう帰ってしまったんですね
だから阿鼻猿理経というのは
そういうことでも厳しいもう並じゃないんです
同じことを二度と言うなよと言ったならば
もう殺されていてぐらいの方がいいんだ
お釈迦様の前に これは言うなよと言ったんではないかと
聞くなよと言ったんではないかと
その厳しい世の中で誰のところもないんですよ
でなきゃこの怠け者というのは育てられませんしね
いかに人間の気持ち悪くて屁理屈と言うと
もう もうもう悟りの世界
智慧の世界じゃないんですよ
もう瞑想会に来る時は
2週間前に私はもう菜食主義で有機栽培の食べ物しか食べませんよ
それで聖者来るんですか？とある人はそういう話を聞いてね
だから私は電話を受けなかったんだから
ですから 私 電話を受けたら
ではあなたは来ないでくださいと
あなたの面倒を見る暇がないんだよと
誰かさんが菜食主義で有機栽培で
この何とかマイクロバイオティックの食べ物しか食べないんだと
で だからそのバカのためにこちらでマイクロバイオティック食べ物を用意しておかないと
そのバカがもう億人出家したってもひと欠片も進みませんよ
そのわがままで これ知ってますから
ですから私がということは
まあいいや あなたは来なくてもと
家でやってくださいと
本人はそうですか では私は家でやりますと
家で何やるんですかね
テキストにあるんですかね
お釈迦様の瞑想法は テキストに書けませんよ
テキストにあると思うのは勘違いです
ですから この厳しいというのはそういうことなんですよ
そこで一応私はもうだったらかなり困りますよというところで
では自分の食べ物を全部持ってくるますよということで
まあ食べ物 食べ物 あれこれ持ってきて
ずっとイライライライライライラ状態でね
2日  3日いて帰っちゃうんですね
怒りの瞑想してね だから本当に私は優しくはないんですよ
だから黙ってるんですね
どうぞどうぞと 好きなものを召し上がってくださいと
お休みしたければどうぞ休んでくださいと
あれはみんな優しく優しいと思ってるでしょ
優しくないんです ああいう風な言葉が言おうと
もう人間扱いしていないんですよ
だから親切にすごく寝たければどうぞ
はい おねんねと そういう態度なんです
だからお釈迦様は優しかったんだから
もうそれとは違いますよ
出て行けと そんなにだったら死ねとハッキリ言うんですよ
だったら死ねと 例えば食べ物にちょっとちょっともうちょっとまあなんとか目がない
お前刀みたいなものを腹を切って死になさいよと
そんなこと食うんだったら
お坊さんたちは食べ物にちょっと執着しちゃうでしょうに
美味しいご飯もらうところにちょっとちょっと托鉢にとか
何回なんか行ったりすると
石を真っ赤に焼いて 鉄の玉をね
鉄の玉を真っ赤に焼いて食いなさいよと
どうったことない お前死ぬだけやと
なんどうったことないと
食べ物に執着するなよと
だからそれがもう言葉に絡めればどれほどきついかというと
だから現代語ではお前死んだっても全然気にしませんよと
その方がいいやと 死んでしまえと
こちら来るなよというぐらいの話なんです
だからお釈迦様が言うのは
私が追い出しても 追い出しても
否定しても 否定しても
私のところに それでもみんななぜ来るべきかというと
このお話を聞くために来るべきですよと
この阿鼻猿理経の話よ
エーカンタ・ヴィラーガ・ニロダ・ニッバーナ・アヴィンナヤ・ニッバーナヤ・サンワッタティという話を聞くために来るべきですよと
因果法則はなんぞやとかね
もう輪廻はなんなのかとかね
五蘊とはもう五蘊は五蘊ですか
本当に十個・十蘊ですかとかね
そういう話は誰が聞いてもいいですなさい
ですから この弟子入りだから
やっぱりこのすごい師弟関係で
もう生々しい関係なんですよ
学問的な関係って生々しくはないんですよ
単なる遊びだけのことで
知識的なね ですから お釈迦様に直々に会った人々っていうのは
もう まあたとえ鬼がもう一万匹いたっても全然気にしないと思いますよ
あらゆる所から恐ろしい鬼たちが来て
もうあなたを脅してやるぞという
もうあんたのことなんのことはない
あんたのこと全然もう気に-あっち行きなさいと
こちらの方がものすごい怖いと
それくらいもうきつく育てたんです
だからその厳しさっていうのは
お釈迦様はすごいもう
もうきつい言葉を使ったこと自体がお釈迦様の限りない慈しみの慈悲であって
ですから この 私は毎日朝七時八時に起きますから
もう瞑想できっこないんだとかなんとか言っちゃうと
そうですね しょうがないですね
もう慣れていることだからと私は必ず言いますよ
それ自体 この中で一番不親切な言葉なんですよ
食って寝るためだから
家で食って寝ればいいし
瞑想会では五時に起こるんだったら
たとえその人はもう八十年間
七時八時まで寝ていたっても
瞑想会に来たら五時に起きることなんですよ
正しく指導するんだったら
五時に起きてないんだったら
その場で荷物をまとめて追い出すこと
出て行きなさいと 今すぐ
それぐらいやらないと人を育てることはできないんです
それぐらい心っていうのは汚くて怠けているんです
それで弟子関係 お釈迦様には
お釈迦様のところに弟子入りする場合は
お釈迦様のありがたいお説法を聞くためではありません
お釈迦様とちょっとご一緒に生活するんですよ
まあそばではいませんだけど
まあそこら辺 他のそこら辺を周りで生活している
でもお釈迦様がいるところで生活しているんだから
喉を鳴らすことさえも禁止なんですよ
それほど楽じゃないんです
とか喉を鳴らすのはダメなんです
お釈迦様 皆さん それでも誰ですかと
音立てずなど その厳しさは並じゃないんですよ
ですからみんなもう本当にもう例えば風邪なんか引いて
もう咳が出ても すごい苦労して音を立てないように頑張ってるんです
全然お釈迦様にこれぐらいは病気だからしょうがないでしょうとは一言言ったら
もうそれで終わり もう出ていけて
お前私のところにいるべき人ではありませんと
怠け者やと だから一番難しいのはくしゃみなんですよ
くしゃみはしないんだから
お釈迦様のところで誰一人も
まあ咳ぐらいはなんとかなんとか
くしゃみはどうしますかね
くしゃみが出ても どうせ埃やらいっぱいあるところで
普通に座ってね 地面に座ってるでしょうに
くしゃみが出ても みんなとにかく我慢して我慢して
鼻をなんとかしてなんとかして
これをもう音を立てないように気をつけるんです
だからそれぐらい神経あると悟れないと思いますか？だからみんなもう何のことなく淡々と悟るんです
だからお釈迦様とは言ったら
まあ一日二日でもほとんど終わりますからね
悟る 悟ったところで お釈迦様はなんのことなくすごく褒めてあげるんだからね
完全悟りがいたらね すごく褒めてあげるし
まあそれでもこちらにいる必要性がないということでね
そこがもう自由にしなさいと
それでみんな自由に生活するんですよ
托鉢して何か召し上がって
気楽に瞑想もしながら
それで生活はする 修行中ということで
お釈迦様のところに弟子入りに行ったら
もう命の覚悟でいた方がいいんです
死ぬか悟るかどちらにするのでしょうということであり
だからそれでありがたいことは
この仏教ではね 仏教のお釈迦様も考えている
この師弟関係っていうのはそんなもんです
だからそういう話はどんな話かというと
このスッタン・ゲイヤン・ゲイヤー・カラナン・ジャータカン・ウダーナン・アブダワルナン・ウェーダルランとかなんとかという
ここを捨すの方とか 学問的な方ですね
その代わりにお釈迦様が修行するとき
喋る説法はアッピッチャカタ・サントゥッティカタ
アッピッチャカタ・アッピッチャっていうのはもう小欲の話
やっぱりそれはもう論理的にも対策的と思想として生き方として
小欲は喜ぶこと サントゥッティカタっていうのはもう何でしたっけ？知足のこと
小欲と知足 パヴィヴェーカカタ
パヴィヴェーカカタっていうのは
やっぱり一人で生活することは一番ありがたいと
いろんなもうたくさん仲間を作る話ではなくて
たくさん仲間を作って
建物を作って 家を作って
もう贅沢せず 贅沢ではなくて
楽に生活するっていう話ではなくて
離れましょう 離れましょうと
友達から離れましょうと
一人で生活しましょうという話ですね
アサンサッガカタ サンサッガっていうのは
みんなと交わすというかね
交わす話なんですね 仲良くする話で
アサンサッガっていうのは
みんなからどうすれば離れて離れて離れて一人で生活できるんでしょうかという
ヴィリヤアランダカタ
努力精進の話 シーラカタ
自分を戒める話 サマーディカタ
禅定の話 パンニャーカタ
智慧の話 それからヴィモッティカタ
解脱の話とヴィモッティニャーナ・ダッサナカタ
解脱を得た人の智慧の話
智慧二種類ですよ シーラ・サマーディ・パンニャーのパンニャー
シーラは戒 サマーディは定
パンニャーは慧で まあ戒めの話で
サマーディの話と智慧の話ですね
それから解脱の話が出てきて
それから解脱を得た人の話
智慧の話がまた出てくるんです
このような話はブッダがするんだと
その話を聞いて勉強するために
私に私が追い出しても追い出しても
私のところに来て 弟子として修行した方がいいと
[背景音楽]じゃああの
これで今日で終了になりますかね
もうちょっと 四十五 十六
十七 なんかないな うん
まあどうしますかね かなり長いなね
全部終了に持ってきますかね
十分で終了することもできます
で まあ一応そのように弟子 rules するんですね
また次にまあ一通りからつなげていくと
このようであれば アーナンダよ
師の災いが生じますと
これから次の問題に持っていくんで
師の えーと 何でしたっけ
師の災いが生じます このようであれば弟子の災いが生じます
このようであれば 奉行者の災いが生じます
ではアーナンダよ どの師の災いが生じるのか
というところで 師弟関係の次の問題
とにかく師弟関係であろうが
関係だから決していいものじゃないんですよ
苦しみが生まれるんですよ
どんな関係でも 生命との関係っていうのは苦しみの災いの元なんで
それたとえお釈迦様と弟子との関係だとしたって関係だからね
そういうことで あらゆるこのウパッダ
災いが生まれてくるんだと
だから師から出てくる
まずい めんどくさいこと
それからアンテーワーダ・シッラ
弟子のいろんな性格の悪さから
いろんなトラブルが出てくる
ブラフマチャリーヤ・ウパッダっていうのはやっぱり実践ですね
実践する 修行する そのものにまた関係なくいろいろ災いが生まれてくると
実践しようとするんだけど
何かトラブルが起こるということ
そこで師から生まれてくる災いは何なのかというと
イダ・アーナンダ カタンチャ・アーナンダ
アーチャリユット アーチャリーユーパッデヴォ シーノーワサワイワナンナノカ
で アーナンダ エカッチョーサッター ヴィヴィッタンセーナースナン バジャティ アランニャン ドゥッカムーラン パッバタン カンガタ
ある もう シーが  離れている森やらね
木の下やら 山やら もう
洞窟やらね お墓やら そういうどこかに人がいないところで生活するんですね
タッサ タターウパカッタッサ ヴィーヘラトー アナーバッタニ ブラーマナガハパティカ アネーガ マーチェーワ ジャナパダータ
ふんふんふんふんふんふん
まあそんな難しくないんだから
淡々と読めばいいんです
それで洞窟などなど生活しますね
あの 藁とかね 青汁の  このように隠居して住んでいる彼の元に
町や地方のバラモン シサンカたちが訪ねてきます
彼は 訪ねてき くる町や地方のバラモン
シサンカたちに対して
迷い ですかね 欲し かな
欲し むさぼり サシに転じます
サシって何ですかね  贅沢
え？贅沢？ 贅沢  うん だから
シー まあそういうことになるんだと
アーナンダよ これが 災いのある死と言われます
死の災いによって 汚れのある
再生を伴わず 恐ろしいこの果報を備えた未来に生まれ
生まれと老いと死がある
諸々の悪しき不善の法が彼を打ち
何でしたっけ つけます
アーナンダよ このような死の
災い  うん 日本語で読んだらわからなくなっちゃう
[笑い]アワディンスナーマ
まあとにかくこの 悟れないってことでですね
言って なんか日本語で悟るんだっていう風に言ってるような感じがしたんだけど
それは読み違いかもしれませんですけど
死の災いによって汚れるのある
果報を備えた未来に生まれと老いと死がある
諸々の悪しき不善法が彼を打ちつけますってどういう意味ですか？不善法が打ちつけますね
それ負けるってことですね
うん そこで善声はちょっと気が弱いんですね
で それで もう本当に欲のないきつい
もう藁の腐ってるところとか
そういうところで生活してるかもしれませんけども
そういうところにどうせもう俗人たちが来て
もう説法を聞いたりすると
いろいろいろいろ  贅沢させちゃうと
だからみんな持ってくるものだからしょうがなく使っていて
やっぱりしょうがなく使うのはいいんだけど
自分も知らないうちに
この贅沢の生き方に引っ張られてしまうということになる
それは死の災いやと いわゆる心がまだ脆いっていうところは
頑固じゃないんですよ
じゃああなた言うんだったら
まあせっかくだからちょっと酒一杯飲みましょうというね
このせっかくだからって一言葉でもう人間失格なんですよ
せっかくではなくて [笑い]まあせっかくだから
それはもうせっかくだから失格なんですよ
だからまあ仏教ではせっかくだからってないんですよ
もしあったら  もう失格です
[笑い]ね だからせっかくの論理っていうのはね
やっぱり相手のことを気にすることでしょ
いわゆる相手によって自分がすごく揺らぐっていうことなんですよ
だからそれだったらもう危険でしょうに
どんな場面でもせっかくりちゃうんだからね
まあ断るときでも 日本ではね
せっかくですけど断りますというふうにも言いますけどね
まあまあ それはその時はいいんですけどね
まあ一応そうやってね
社会からね いろんな贅沢やらいろんなものを持ってくると
なんとなくずるずると心がそこら辺に回転してしまっちゃうと
もう心は誘惑されてる状態なんですね
その生 こんな弱い心で
まあもしかするとその先生は立派な先生で
あの もしかしたら悟ってるかもしれませんよ
悟っていても もしかすると
もうちょっと贅沢にちょっと足が引っ張られるという
そういう先生のところに弟子入りした人はなかなかダメですよと
悟れないんだと だからその先生の性格にあるこの微かな弱みというか
この緩いところが問題になるんだと
だから恐ろしくもう頑固でなきゃもう
だから弟子たちが 例えばもう食べ物もなかなかでお腹が空いていて
そこで誰かが食べ物をやっぱり持ってきたんだと
先生から見れば ちょっとこの持ってきたやり方がちょっと間違ってると
あるいは弟子一人がちょっと誰かに話をしたんだと
本当は先生ってみんなもうもう二日間もご飯も食べてないんだよとかなんか
それで先生はなんかそれ感知するという
こいつはなんか信者さんに言ったんではないかと
それじゃあ信者さんが別にそれとあまり関係なく
やっぱりもうごちそうを持ってきましょうと
ごちそう持って 先生だったら厳しくて食うなよと言うかもしれません
捨てなさいと 弟子たちは二日間も食べてないんだから
もうちょっと食べたってもいいんじゃないか
いえ 違います 食べてもよくないと
せっかくですから捨てなさいと
せっかくですけど それぐらい強くないと
あの 育てることはできないんだよという話なんです
ですから 人間の性格バラバラだから
まあ少々ちょっと調整してあげる人々っていうのは結構世の中でいるし
仏教ってかなり調整してあげるということをやってはいますよ
別に仏教は頑固な教えじゃないんだから
かなり調整しますよ 調整はするんだけど
師弟関係になると まあもう死んでしまえと
調整はなしと そこら辺が違うんですよ
それが先生の弱みですね
そうなるとなかなか悟れなくなっちゃうんだと
次は えーとえーとえーと
[紙をめくる音]ええええええ
エヴァンゴレンでアーチャリーはカタンチャアナンダアンテーヴァー suppaddho хоティ
タッサエーヴァコーパナアナンダサットゥサーアポ
タッササットゥヴィヴェーカムアヌブルーハヤマアヌンヴィッタムセーナーサナムパティティアラニャンルックムーラムパッバタムカンダラングリグハン・スサーナム
・ヴァナパッタン・アッブオーカーサン・パラーラプンジャン・タッサタターアウーパカータッサヴィヒェルットアナワッタニ
同じことですね まあ弟子も弟子で
先生に従って森の中で一人で生活していると
もう苦労しながら修行している途中で
いろいろ在家の人々が来て拝んだりするところで
もし堕落しちゃうんだったら
もうそれでダメですよと
それからブラフマチャリーヤウパアーパッド
ブラフマチャリーヤ修行の業は一体何でしょうかと
じゃあこの二つをちょっと考えてください
で みんなこのみんなではなくて
この仏教にはもうちゃんと仏教を勉強していない
好き勝手に本を開けて読むだけの
ものすごい金メダル上げるべき
ノーベル賞をあげるべき天才たちが世の中にいるんですよ
だからほんま何回読破して
これはもういいやとかね
で だからもうすごい困りますけど
困ってはないんだけど
殺したいくらいのあり方いうのもできますけど
まあただ何か読んだだけでわかるわけじゃないんですよ
だからこれでもこの表面的に読めば
あの腐ってる 例えば道具や藁の藁が腐っているところで
それで座り込んでいれば
それこそ修行はそれこそ悟りだという意味で取れるんですよ
そういう意味じゃないんです
だから基本的には人から何も認めない生活だから
森の中に 木の下に生活するのは当たり前で
すごく穏やかな気持ちで
これで十分やと 木の下があるんじゃないか
これで修行できるんだぞということは
それは基本中の基本で
で そこからもう木の下に満足していたい
いてほしいんですよ 喜びを感じていてほしいんですよ
この小欲知足が大事ですよ
それでまあ誰かが信者さんがね
木の下に何か敷物何もないでしょ
じゃあこれ敷いてこの上に座ってくださいと言ったら
まあ捨てますということじゃないんですよ
で それを敷いてその上に座ってもいいんですけど
心変えてはいけないんですね
小欲知足の心は変えてはいけないんですよ
だからそれはきちんと守っておかないと
で どんどん品物入るたびに自分の生活基準
水準を自分で変えちゃうと
もう心が堕落しているんですね
だから徹底的に言ったら
この心の弱みなんですね
でないとジャイナ教と同じくもうお布施を受け取るなよということにもなってしまっちゃうんですよ
木の下に座れと そこでなきゃ修行ではありませんと
それだったら木の下に座ってるみんなも全員修行完了者でしょうに
だから私はまるっきりもう仏教じゃないと言っている人にも言って
私はもう手紙書いたんですよ 10
時半で新宿の南口で会いましょうと
あなたにいっぱい阿羅漢たちを会わせてあげますと 12
時半になっちゃう 新宿の南口で阿羅漢たちだらけですよ
だからただお風呂に入らないで臭いだけでね
住むところはないだけで
昼間公園に寝て 夜はもう新宿の南口の駅のところで寝るだけで悟りというわけじゃないんですよ
だからこの性格の問題なんだ
きちんとした頑固な性格を持っているかっていうことなんですね
だからこの心はもう揺らぎない
たとえ贅沢な食べ物を食べても
何も食べ物なくても 小欲知足の心はそのままね
持っていくと だから贅沢に溺れないことがね
贅沢は生きないってことは
いくら持ってきたって
ありがとうございますとかなんとか言って受け取るかもしれませんだけど
自分の心はそんなもんではめげないというところが
お釈迦様がおっしゃっているところなんですね
だからこの目的は輪廻を断つことなんですよ
あの腐りかけてる藁のところに寝ているかないかということじゃないんだ
あなた寝ている 藁敷いて寝てるでしょ
藁腐ってるんで 腐ってないでしょうと
ダメですよと そんな話じゃないんですよ
藁が腐ってなきゃダメです
だからそんな形の世界じゃないんですよ
あなたは輪廻を断ちましたと
不善から心をね 綺麗にしたんですかと
そこら辺はもうすごく目的だからね
だからずっと一生腐ってる藁の中の生活したってても
心は悪のまんまだったら何の意味もないでしょうに
だからこの形ではありません
この心の頑固さ 正確なんですね
寝てる性格だったら悟れないと
そこで修行の邪魔っていうのは
イデ
アナンダ タッタガタ ロケ ウッパ ジャティ アラハント サッマサン ブッドウ イッチャ チャラ サンプア
ンノ スガト ロカ ヴィドゥ アヌットロ プルシサマサーリプッタ サッターデーマヌッサナム ブッドウガガワ
それでお釈迦様が現れるんだと
こういうこういうここの特色がありますね
それでお釈迦様はヴィヴィッタンセーナアサナンバジャティ
お釈迦様は人々から離れたところに生活します
アランニャ ルッカムーラ 森やら木の下やら
パッバタンヤマ カンダランはわかりません
ギリグワンというのは洞窟とかね
スサーナンというのは墓地
でワナパッタンというのは森
アッボーカーサンというのは空き地
パララプンジャンというのはこの藁の捨てているところですね
タッサタッター ルーパカッタッサ ヴィヘラト アンワーワッテニ バーフマナ
それでまたバラモン人たちやらどんどん出てくるんだと
そこでこのバラモン人たちから世間形たちが来ても
お釈迦様は アナワッテス
全然転落はしません で
ナムッチャティカーノヤティ
ああ これがいいな これが欲しいなとか
あのバラモンたちが持ってくるものについては全然もう使ってはいるんだけど
全然もう欲はない ね ゲーダティ
欲張ることは全くないと
ナアワッテティバフリャ
贅沢 贅沢に転落することは全く
全くない お釈迦様は だからお釈迦様も森の中に生活しているんだけど
それで大勢の人々がそちらに来たら
もうすぐそこにあるやっぱり贅沢な世界が現れちゃうんですね
いくら物質的な物理的な贅沢な世界が現れたって
お釈迦様の心は全然転落はしないと
あの状態を守っているんだと
タッセコパナーニサトゥサコタッササトゥイエカンアニュト
ブルハイマーナヴィリッタセーナーサナンバジャティアランヤルックムラパッバタムカンダランジャ
タッサタターウパカッタサヴィヒルトアナワッタティ
で それで弟子がどうなるんですかね
そこでお釈迦様が森の中に生活していると
バラモンって最下の人々がすごい贅沢を持ってきて
そこで大変なことにする
お寺作ったりとか でもお釈迦様は全然それにとらわれることなく
もうお布施は使いますけど
全然とらわれることなく清らかな心でいると
で 弟子もいるんでしょうね
弟子たちも師と一緒に森の中に生活を始めたんだけど
このもう人々が入ってくると
ずるずると心が転落してしまって
贅沢の方へ それで彼には立派な先生がいるにも関わらず
修行ができなくなっちゃうんですね
だから先生はいいんだけど
弟子の心がちょっと贅沢にもうもうなんとなく負けちゃいますから
傾いちゃうんだから それで修行に邪魔
まだ修行中だから心に汚れあるのは当たり前なんですけど
やっぱりそれでも贅沢にちょっと転落しようかなという気持ちで
もう修行に邪魔なんですよと
災いですよと その 3つを勉強しなさいと
先生の災い 弟子の災い
それからまあ修行の災いと
その 3つの中でバクマチャーリーヤウパードというものが
いわゆる先生の災いも大したことはないと
もう弟子の災いも大したことない
でも修行に災いが生まれるんだったら
これ大変な危険だと ドゥッカヴィパークタローチェーヤカトゥクヴィパークタローチェーヤ
アピチャヴィニパーターエサンワッタティ
ですから 修行する弟子がもう美味しいものを食べられてよかったなとか
ちょっとニコッと微笑みながら美味しいものを食べちゃっても
真面目に修行するんだったら大丈夫ですよ
今日は寝るときはちょっと敷く敷物をもらっちゃって
なんか暖かく寝られたなとかね
それでちょっと素直に喜んだっても
その大した危険ではないと
それ危険は危険なんですけどね
喜ぶなよ そんなことでということは厳しくあるんだけど
でも修行に邪魔になっちゃうと
例えば瞑想しながら美味しいもの食べちゃったけど
あれ美味しかったなとかってなっちゃうのはダメなんですね
もう食べる時はもうまあまあ美味しいんじゃないかなと
それでもうきれいさっぱり忘れちゃうと
お釈迦様はたち美味しいものであると
もう執着で食べてますけど
弟子がやっぱり美味しいなとかね
これとかねと思ったり食べたりと
その場合は先生たちはこいつはなんか美味しがってるんだ
これを食べなさい 自分のものをやってまでもあげることはやりますよ
君はなんか好きみたいだから
じゃあこれも食べなさい
私の分も で それはちょっとしたね
人間のね ちょっとした弱みだから
そこは本当はあんまり危険ということではないんだけど
瞑想するたって あの食べ物ばっかり浮かんで美味しかったな
美味しかったなとかね
明日もにもらうかなとかね
そういうことになると
もう頭が混乱してるんですね
それで修行できないので
それこそ徹底した邪魔だと
その 3つの災いの中から修行の災いは一番災いだと
えーと チャスマティヒマンアーナンダミッタワターヤサムジャチャヤテマサッパッタワターヤ
それはどういう意味ですかね
だからアーナンダよ 私のことは友人だと思いなさいって意味なんですよ
敵やと思うなよと まあ死んでしまえと言うんだけど
お釈迦様は 言う時は言うんだけど
でも私は友人やと思いなさいと
敵やと思うなよと どういう風に日本訳はなってます？それで言うアーナンダ私に対して友
友誼を持って行動しなさい
敵を持って行動してはなりませんということで
そこで師弟関係はぴったし決めてます
お釈迦様っていうのは本当にもうそういうミッタータヤーというすごい友人やと
戦友やと 敵だと思うなよと
そこでお釈迦様を友人に
戦友にする方法を次に説明するんですね
イダーナンダサッターサーカーンダンマンドーセディアヌカンパコヒテーシアヌカンパムターダヤ
それであの師はあの弟子たちのことを心配して
あの法を説くと イダンを控えイダンを使いやと
これは君たちには役に立ちます
これは君たちの幸福になりますと
タッササーヴァカーネスッスーサンティネソータンゴウダンティアンニャンチッタンウパッキャベンティ
こうしなさい こうしなさいと言うんだけど
弟子の連中は全然聞いてくれないと
あっちこっち聞いて心が行ってるんだと
ウォッカンナジャサットゥサーサナワッタンティ
お釈迦様の教えからはみんな脱線する
話聞かない エワンコアーナンドサッターランサーヴァカサッパッタワターサムダーチャランティノーミッタワター
もしお釈迦様は一生懸命心配して喋っているのに
あっち見たりこっち見たり
あまりあそう あ 何でしたっけ？とかね
で この前そういう腹が立つことあったんです
せっかく話したのに何？と聞いたんです
その瞬間でもう二度と顔を合わせるなよと言いたくなったんだけどね
だからそういう風な仏教は難しいんですよ
甘えて怠けてね 私にも
私は普通のバカな人間かもしれませんだけど
このブッダの世界背負ってるんだからね
私にもどうすることもできないんですよ
あんた ちょっとこれ何とかしてくれと言ったって
もう自分が運転しているのはある決まりの乗り物だからね
それは何とかできませんよ
で 飛行機に乗ったら えっ
私のしょちょうっていうで
あんたパイロットさんもうもう仲がいいんじゃないか
そこら辺ちょっと降りてくれと言ったっても
それはできませんよ もう
決まりだから もう決まりじゃなくて法則だから
次の空港場に行くまでもうどうにもならん
まあそれでお釈迦様が指導説法するしているのにも関わらず
あまり聞く耳を持たないとか
まあそうですか じゃあこのうちやってみますとかね
そういう感じになること自体がお釈迦様を敵に回していることやと
それが偉大なるお釈迦様を自分が敵だ敵だ敵だと思っていることやと
だからあんた方地獄に落ちるんだ
しょうがないんですよ
カタンチャーナン・サッターナン・サーガ・ミッタヤ・サーエ・サムダーチャランテ
お釈迦様に対して友誼を持って
そんなに素晴らしい友人やと思って生活する方法は何なのかというと
お釈迦様は一生懸命心配して説法するでしょうに
その説法はきちんと聞いてくださいと
あっちこっち心は脱線しないで
じっと集中して聞いてくださいと
聞いたら まああなた方の長い間の幸福になりますよと
それが タン・ウォー・バビ・セッディーガラ・タン・ヒタエ・スカーヤ
ノー
・ウォー・アハン・アーナンダ・タター・パラッカ・ニッサーミ・ヤター・クンバカーロ・アーマケ・アーマカマッテ・ニッガイハ・ニッガイヤハン・アーナンダ・ワッカハミ
ポワイハ・パワイハ・パワイハ
ヨー・サーロソ・タッサティーティ
この最後のパテはすごい立派なんですよ
それを日本訳をちょっと見てみます
アーナンダ 私に対して友誼を持って行動しなさい
敵意を持って行動してはなりません
それは長い間 そなたたちの利益のために
安楽のためになるはずです
アーナンダよ 私はあたかも
読めない 何？陶工？陶工が生の乾いているものに対するように
乾いていないですね  何？乾いていないものに対するように
そなたたちに対して努力することがありません
努力することはありません
どういう意味ですかね
アーナンダよ 私は抑え抑え解きます
アーナンダよ 私は囲み囲み解きます
真実なるものがとどまるはずです
ん？ 時間をかけて指導するって意味じゃないの？全体から
この文の中から  うーん
今日は ナヴォ・アハン・アーナンダ・タター・パラッカ・ニッサーミ
生の状態で 努力することはないっていうのは
ほっとく？みたいな  違うんですよ
ニッガイ・ニッガイハン・アーナンダ・ワッカハミ
だからこの陶器って言ったって
もうこれはすごく乱暴に扱うできますよ
もう焼いたきちんととしたものだったら
生だったらどうしますかね
だから陶器の なんていうか
大工 大工とやなんか何さんでしたっけ？陶工が
これ土がすごく生々しい土でしょ？まだまだ乾いてないでしょうに
だからそれは扱うときはすごく丁寧に扱って
叩いたりして もうへったりして
もう削ったり いろんなことをして
手を加えて  手を加えて丁寧に扱うんですよ
それから焼いて もうきちんと芯のあるものにするんです
だからお釈迦様に叩かれても
もう抑えられても 潰されても
まあそれは陶工と同じ気持ちやと
とにかく立派な作品 最後にもう出して見せるんやと
いくらかできた陶器 なんか欠け落ちあるんだったら
また全部潰しちゃって
またもう一度練って またやってみるってことをいくらでもあるでしょうに
だからまあ 昔はね よく叩くんですよ
生 生 土を 叩く場合は叩いて叩いて薄くするんですよ
で あの なんとかロフロウで回してる間もね
やっぱりこうやってポンポン叩いて叩いて
丁寧に叩いてね だからかなりもう神経使う仕事なんです
やってくる 叩いてくることなんですけどね
だからこの生の粘土を扱ってる
あの陶工みたいと同じく
お釈迦様は人間をもうかなり丁寧に扱ってる
乱暴はしませんと だからな
パラッカマミっていうのは
この乱暴しないということなんです
だからまだまだ生の陶器だから
その期待をしてないんですよ
だからもう陶器を生で売っていいんですよ
水くんでくださいということはない
だからちゃんとそこら辺は考えて考えて
調整して 調整して 一旦火にかけて焼いて戻ってから
もう仕事にはなりますからね
そういう風に このいきなり乱暴に何とかっていうことはしてないんだから
敵ではありませんと ブッダは
だからあの 生の乾いてない粘土を扱うようにもう叩くところを叩いて
運ぶところは運んで ここら辺にもうちょっと粘土持っていこうとかね
ここら辺はちょっと伸ばしておこうとかね
そうやって運ぶところを運んで
押さえるところを押さえてやって陶器を作るんでしょうに
生の間は 生の間は だから乱暴はしないんだと
そこで あの 例えばロクロを回している時でも
大体軽く手を指を入れるだけでしょうに
それちょっとでも間違ったら出てこないんですよ
だからこの手か指か この入れ方っていうのはものすごく優しくて
すごくこの角度を決めて
この強すぎ 強くもなく
柔らかくもないという
このこのちょうどいい
このこれ なかなかできないでしょうに
それで一旦形ができたってもの
元の粘土から切ってもらわなくちゃいけないでしょうに
これは素人にいくら頼んだってできないでしょうに
できる人はちゃんとはい
出来上がった じゃあ自分でこの糸
なんか糸で切るでしょ
あれは 糸をサッと持っていくだけのことなんですけど
まあ見る限り簡単単純です
では誰かに頼んで はい
これ取ってください 慣れてないとまるっきりできないんだから
ロクロを回してるんだから
ただ糸をこうやって持ってきて
それからこれ取るだけのことなの
それでこちゃんとなっちゃいますからね
ですから その丁寧で すごく気をつけて
この生の粘土を扱っているような感じで
私はあんた方を管理しているんだと
やがて芯のあるものが出るんでしょうと
ということですから すごいいい例えだと思いますね
ヨーサロ・ソ・タッサティーティ
そこでどうせ粘土の世界ではしっかりできたものをちゃんとなんとかに入れて
あれ 何て言いますか 窯に入れて焼いて
しっかりした作品というのが出てくる
出来の悪いものはそのまま処分しちゃう
もう関係ないと ですから
やっぱりみんな百パーセント悟るってことはないんです
やっぱり言うことやってくれない
なんかいい加減だったらもう
もう作品うまくできてない作品ですから
そのままそのまま追い出ちゃうという
だから陶器の場合もね
やっぱりもう百ぐらい作ったっても
まあ役に立つのはまあ二十とか三十とか
まあ人はすごいプロだったらね
まあ九十個ぐらいもできるかもしれませんだけど
一般の人の場合  百個作っちゃうとね
まあまあ三十ぐらいせいぜい良い作品のこと
そこから全部もうダメとなりますよ
まあとにかくこの大空
空性というものを説明しようとする
お釈迦様はあらゆる方面で話を持っていって
ものすごい綺麗に話を進む
パーフェクトに終了させるんですよ
だから空ってどのように見るべきかと
空とこの涅槃に悟りに関係とかね
ちょっと一つ だからものすごい膨大な経典なんです
膨大な内容が入っています
だから何回何回も読み直して読み直してしないとね
まあだから日本語で読んでも
このあの生きてる意味が通らないことはまあ通らないんです
それはまあもう私が威張ってるのかいうわけではなくて
まあそれは経典のあり方で
訳では生きてる意味は通らないんです
訳は正しく間違ってるわけじゃないんですけどね
でも釈言の話みたいなもので
何やとわからなくなっちゃうんですね
回向の文仏法僧の根本に礼拝して
戒を守り 慈悲の明想とヴィパッサナーの修行によって得られたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らしますよう
そして解脱を得ますよう
どうもありがとうございました
どうもありがとうございます